the time has finally come
to unleash the forbidden spell of Sahara
upon our enemies what were you thinking
charging right into an enemy's trap as
you and I are one
I too am trapped within this void in
time our hearts and minds will cease to
be are you prepared to die I thought as
much I also do not wish to die and yet
there is no other choice you must join
smash huh join smash brothers already
what in the world are you waiting for
so joining smash consumes even the
darkness itself
[Music]
so you returned and sooner than expected
I see too many swordsmen are there and
you you wield the sword as well what
will you do so that is how you plan to
win the day so be it
I rewards your cleverness this time
[Music]
how is this Oh have anyone you should be
a big handle the heroes relics Eric Foss
strength with superior reach
[Music]
use a Mears overwhelming power
unleash the blinding speed of mail not
along with the sword to create each
weapon matches a direction
[Music]
don't mind me now let's work to you
[Music]